[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce rendez-vous spécial
photo avec notre photographe et
chroniqueur photo Claude chose bonjour
bonjour Patrice comment allez-vous ça va
moi ça va très bien vous aussi très bien
ça va d'autant mieux que vous nous avez
amené si je peux dire quelqu'un qui est
qui a fait qui a fait un livre
absolument formidable et qui fait aussi
des des des photos assez incroyable en
DELTAL on va parler avec lui c'est
francant à moteur parapente à motur
voilà oui il nous expliquera la
différence Francis tac bonjour bonour
alors vous êtes dans le civil vous êtes
ingénieur tout à fait mais quelqu'un
cident
m'ont m m'ont arrêté de travailler il y
a il y a 2 ans puisque je me suis casser
le coup en Albanie dans dans dans ces
dans dans l'exploration des frontières
de l'Albanie en paramoteur je pourrais
je pourrais je pourrais vous l'évoquer
mais à partir de ce moment-là je suis
revenu
d'Albanie en avion privé parce que comme
je voulais expliquer je me suis cassé le
coup et à partir de ce moment-là j'ai
arrêté mon activité d'ingénieur d'accord
et et vous avez été toujours photographe
toute votre vie non oui oui tout à fait
oui tout à fait enfin ça fait ça fait
plus de 40 ans que que me consacre à ça
et puis j'ai donc fait quelques ouvrages
avec mon ami Jacques de Givri sur la
vallée de la Bièvre et deux ouvrages sur
5qutin enine sur Saint-Quentin et là un
ouvrage sur Buc qui s'appelle héritage
euh alors qui est assez formidable parce
que on voit des
photos de de d'endroit où on n pas
auquel on n pas accès généralement c'est
ça oui la plupart des gens sont un peu
surpris par le le contenu de cet ouvrage
puisque évidemment il s'adresse
essentiellement au buquis même si est
les Versaillais les habitants de la
veille de la Bièvre il trouvent un
intérêt euh
mais à titre d'exemple on pourra parler
de la de Bu voilà alors déjà le alors on
peut on peut regarder comme ça c'est
cette photo là on peut s'arrêter un
instant alors voilà la la célèbre
machine de bu que j'ai fait redessiner
machine qui est un patrimoine oublié
puisque euh ça figure évidemment dans
les comptes les comptes du roi à savoir
que le second projet de Colbert pour
amener l'eau au château de
versaill déjà dans les années
1665 jusqu'à
1670 donc le second projet c'était de
remonter l'eau de la Bièvre jusqu'au
château de versaill donc à ce propos il
a fait construire sur la Bièvre à Buc à
l'emplacement aujourd'hui de l'étend de
la jeuneste il a fait construire une une
roue qu'on a nommé la machine de Buin et
qui était qui a été faite en fait 10 ans
avant la machine de Marley parisque tout
le monde me répète sans cesse la machine
de Marley qui a été extrêmement
documenté mais la machine de elle
précède celle de Mar mais elle avait
exactement le même principe puisque
prototype en fait c'était si vous voulez
il y avait des espèces de pistons qui
étaient des des cylindres de de bois qui
rentraient dans des puis cimentés à la
Cha et qui exerçaient sur l'eau de la
Bièvre une pression qui devait remonter
la colline de satori alors là ce qu'on
voit c'est quoi c'est c'est donc c'est
cette machine de Buc que j'ai fait
redessiné par une amie artiste Sarah le
tousé et est-ce qu'on aperçoit là est-ce
qu'on aperçoit sur la la la droite de de
l'image et qui a été qu'on peut qu'on
peut dont on peut discuter parce que
c'est assez extraordinaire ça s appelé
ça s'appelaé le fer de l'uny puisque
c'était le Moulin de l'UNET mais il faut
savoir que depuis les Romains on avait
fait absolument aucun progrès dans le
domaine de l'hydraulique d'accord et
l'eau circulé par des tuyaux fait de de
de tronc et viidé h ou euh de tuyau fait
de de terre cuite voir à la fin un peu
en plomb un peu en cuivre le plomb étant
trop lourd le cuivre étant dispendieux
je ne sais quoi on a commencé là à cette
époque- làà et c'est les premiers tuyaux
de de fer enfin de fonte à l'époque de
fonte mais c'est sont des tuyaux qui
font donc on va dire 20 cm de diamètre
60 cm de long j' j'en ai aperçu à
proximité de la la ferme du trou salé
qui qui traîne comme ça dans dans les
champs mais vous imaginez ce sont des
sections comme ça et c'est ce sont les
premiers tuyaux de fonte de qui ont été
exploité c'est-à-dire qu'on a on a
retrouvé à travers justement tous ces
projets gigantesqu pour pour amener l'au
château de Versailles on a on a
redécouvert l'hydraulique on a réinventé
si vous voulez toutes cette technolog il
Fall inventer tout un système parce que
si je puis me permettre dans les projets
d'amener l'eau à versaill le le premier
projet qui a été dénoncé par laabé
Picard c'était de de faire venir de
dévier la Loire pour emener l'au à
Versailles le second ça a été aussi de
faire d'utiliser l'eau de de de l'UR par
le fameux aceduc de maintenant et le
trisème projet a été de effectivement
comme tu le viens de tu viens de
l'expliquer le comment s'appelle la
machine de Marle donc voilà mais ça
c'est c'est des sujets non mais tout ça
c'est bien postérieur que ce soit la
queuc du de maintenant ou euh euh comme
tu me l'expliques la machine de Marley
mais c'est c'est 10 ans plus tard en
fait après après cette machine de Buc
qui montrait quelques quelques
difficultés très efficace euh on a
décidé euh euh on a décidé de remonter à
la minière l'eau de la biève par un
autre BIA et ils ont construit sur les
pentes à guillancour là ils ont
construit cinq moulins alors il y en
avait quatre qui s'étageai sur la pente
et un qui était sur le plateau et et ça
remonté l'eau par palier de 12 m à
partir de l'étan du Val ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'étan du Val d'Or qui était
le premier étan qui a été aménagé les
autres étants comme la jeunesse ça a été
aménagé qu'en 1948 et l'étant du moulin
renard là Guill encour c'est été aménagé
beaucoup plus tard 1960 pourquoi vous
avez choisi Buc non mais j'y habite
depuis depuis depuis depuis plus de 30
ans et il est vrai que la que duuc de
Buc notamment qui lui est arrivé plus
tard puisqu'il est arrivé en
684 pour amener l'eau du plateau de
saclé ça c'était un un autre des projets
d'un ingénieur de euh de Colbert c'est
Gobert Gobert qui a totalement aménagé
le plateau de sa clé avec des rigoles et
ces rigoles en fait amener l'eau dans
ces aceducs souterrains alors ces
aceducs souterrains sont sont maçonnés
et font 1 m de large par 1, 802 haut et
sillonne absolument tout le plateau de
trappe et le plateau de saclé parce que
les EAU de l'étant de trappe qui est un
étord aussi artificielle les eaux des
étendes saclclé et de l'étente du
préclos euh qui était qui était à Buc si
vous voulez toutes ces eaux était drainé
pour après être amené jusqu'à Versailles
comme il fallait franchir la vallée de
la Bièvre à partir du plateau de saclclé
ils ont construit après l'échec des des
des siphons qui descendaient dans la
Bièvre dans dans la vallée de la Bièvre
ils ont construit donc la queedu entre
84 et 86 la grande chance à ce moment-là
c'est que la France exceptionnellement
était en paix donc il y a il y a pas eu
moins de deux régiments de garde suisse
qui s'y sont attelés et c'est pour ça
qu'il a été réalisé en un temps record
parce que cet aqueduc qui aujourd'hui
fait 21 m de haut il il fait en fait 40
46 m parce que vous avez 25 m qui sont
sous le ramblé OUI pour pour franchir la
vallée ououi et euh il a a il y a eu il
a peu de temps des conférences sur le
sujet on pourrait envisager de le
remettre en eau hein ces aceduces
souterrain fonctionne toujours en fait
quand on va dans la fourêt de doméal de
versaill on voit l'endroit où il il
rentre il y a une guitoune là qui est
d'ailleurs sur sur la queeduc et puis on
voit l'endroit où il rentre et qui
ramène l'eau jusqu'aux étendes gbert qui
sont toujours présents à Versailles qui
ont été transformés en jardin alors le
livre s'appelle donc héritage on peut le
trouver bu héritage en l'occurrence
c'est c'est disponible sur mon site
internet francisac.com sinon il est en
vente dans deux trois points à Buc à
savoir la presse de Buc le comptoir de
la
bio j'ai pas j'ai pas été sollicité si
vous et puis j'ai pas le tirage il est
pas il est pas très très important
d'abord pour les gens de bu mais c'est
vrai que les les gens qui s'intéressent
à l'histoire qui s'intéresse voilà la
façon justement don dont bah l'eau est
arrivé jusqu'au jusqu'au ch de versaill
ça peut tout à fait les passionnés oui
j'ai rencontré à cet effet des gens par
exle de véisie qui travaillent sur les
le château de le château de Louvois à
Meon et qui a utilisé toutes ces
techniques si vous voulez un peu plus
tard pour aménager son son château et et
drenéo alors vous êtes aussi vous le
dites vous-même un aventurier du désert
c'est ça oui tout à fait en fait je suis
je suis tombé dedans quand j'étais petit
on va dire puisqu'à l'âge de 20 ans je
suis parti en Égypte en en autostop j'ai
vécu après au Maroc où j'étais
professeur de physique et j'ai
rapidement eu à Casablanca casablan et
en fait si vous voulez très vite il y a
eu l'appel des sables avec avec mes amis
dans les fameuse dune de Merzouga et 15
ans plus tard donc j'ai eu la la la
grande chance de de travailler sur ce
livre dun hein c'est c'était une dizaine
d'années de travail mais c'est le c'est
le tour du monde des des dunes de sable
et pourquoi pourquoi il y a des de sable
quelles sont les formes de ces sables
pourquoi les couleurs qui vit dans le
désert et c'est un c'est un bouquin qui
a été en plus relu par les scientifiques
et qui a fait l'objet de de différentes
versionsch ographique qui en a fait une
version en allemand euh il a été il a
été traduit également en anglais donc
c'est c'est un peu l'ouvrage de
référence c'est un peu ma fierté mais à
ce moment-là si vous voulez je me suis
rendu compte que il était extrêmement
difficile de de survoler les les les
herbes de
sable dans dans les bouts du monde aufin
fond du de la Chine d' les premières
photos de Dune vous les faites en fait
chaque fois qu'il y avait une dune j'
essayé de monter sur la plus haute donc
il y a des gens qui pensent qu'il y a
beaucoup de photos aérienn alors que ce
sont des photos d'une d'une vers une
autre vous voyez il y a qu'en amiie où
on pouvait facilement louer des petits
avions et exercer des images mais et là
là on vous voit alors euh ça c'est
l'Étap d'après c'est vous hein oui tout
à fait donc il y a en fait lié à ce à ce
livre d'une si vous voulez on pour aller
au bout du sujet parce qu'en fait c'est
c'est un sujet inépuisable et des des
des des erges c'est-à-dire des des
ensembles de dunes dans le monde il y en
a un peu dans tous les déserts et ça
représente des surfaces considérables
mais théodormono disait que dans l'herg
orientale il y a dans le dans le sud
dans le sud-est de l'hergue orientale il
y a un phénomène unique au monde qui
sont des dunes des dunes en étoil
disposé comme des neurones alors si on
passe en avion de ligne de de de
l'Afrique noire pour remonter sur
l'Europe on les voit de temps en temps
et donc pendant des pendant des années
j'ai nourri ce projet comment je peux
aller survoler ces dunes parce que il
suffit de se souvenir du du du film Le
Patient anglais pour s'apercevoir qu'un
champ de Dune le matin ou le soir ça
prend une dimension extraordinaire avec
les ombres porté pas le même et donc je
me suis dit j'ai j'ai pas à ma
disposition les hélicoptères de l'armée
il y a pas il y a pas d'avion loc drone
encore il y a pas de drone mais de toute
manière dans les pays dans les pays on
va dire
sarien les drones
aujourd'hui son il sont pas donc en fait
je fais du paramoteur maintenant depuis
depuis une petite quinzaine d'années euh
et à l'époque j'ai suivi j'ai suivi la
voix officielle en demandant donc les
autorisations pour aller à cet endroit
et je ne les ai jamais eu hein alors
j'étais j'étais justement fin janvier à
nouveau dans ces endroits mais tout le
monde était au courant il y avait donc
le wali c'est-à-dire le préfet il y
avait l'armée qui était au courant enfin
là il aurait fallu que j'attende des
jours voir des semaines et je suis pas
quelqu'un de très patient donc j'ai j'ai
voulais pas loin mais ce ce ce projet
j'ai jamais j'ai jamais fait par contre
j'ai continué donc cette aventure des
dunes à travers les bouts du monde et
puis je vous présente par exemple ici
une image qui a été faite qui a été
faite en Chine dans le désert de GO
absolument et donc là avec des photos vu
du ciel grâce au
par en Chine il y a absolument qu'un
problème un me un moteur thermique ils
vont pas vous ils vont pas vous dire que
vous allez randre sur
place chinois non mais ça ça ce sont non
seulement c'est le Gobi chinois c'est
les plus dun du monde mais en plus il a
une particularité c'est qu'au pied de
ces ces dunes et plus elles sont hautes
plus les les lacs sont sont importants
mais il y a de l'eau il y a de l'eau de
ruissellement du plateau du Tibet qui
vient sourdre au pied au pied de ces
lacs et à tel point que si vous l'eau
l'eau est douce si vous creusez un puits
ou si vous creusez juste à côté du lac
parce qu'en surface elle va s'évaporer
et vous avez celles minéraux qui vont
s'accumuler mais à tel point justement
qu'en dousant les les les les les
Mongols de geniscan ont traversé ce ce
ce désert si vous voulez quand ils sont
partis de Mongolie ils traversent le
Gobi pour atteindre la Chine et il passe
là parce qu'il y a de l'eau il il y a de
l'eau et il y a toujours des familles
des familles d'éleveurs mongoles qui
réside dans ce désert voyez donc des
éleveurs de de chameau de chèvres de
mouton et et de chevaux parce que il y a
suffisamment d'eau pour donner à boire
aux chevaux le plus beau paysage que
vous avez vu c'est c'est la Chine
du point de vue des d'unes ou ah c'est
difficile à
dire les plus beaux paysages si vous
voulez là là j'ai je reviens je reviens
il y a quelques jours du du Sud algérien
c'est vrai qu'il y a une telle diversité
mais vous on ne comprend pas à quel
point il y a une telle diversité il y a
des dunes il y a des dunes de toutes les
couleurs il y a des dunes de toutes les
formes il y a des des dunes avec des
rochers il y a des a avec de l'au c'est
c'est tellement vaste le grand TER dont
je vous parlais tout à l'heure c'est
c'est peut-être la moitié de la France
hein il faut s'en rendre compte et après
il y a l'herg chè l'erg occidental
l'herg d'EM l'erg thodï
l'ER frine enfin il y en a une quantité
absolument très importante dans ton
livre parce que je j'ai lu ce ce livre
là donc qui est très intéressant ton
projet
oasis ton projet était quand même de ce
que tu as appeler la
méridien la diagonale àide donc tu es
parti je crois d'Amérique du Sud oui bon
on pe pas tout à fait mais pour
simplifier pour simplifier les les les
déserts si vous voulez dans l'hémisphère
Nord euh sont sur la diagonale aride
c'est-à-dire tout le Sahara tout le
Sahara qui passe par l'Arabie l'Iran et
qui va jusqu'en Chine donc tous les
déserts sont sont disposés de cette
manière-là alors en Chine ils sont plus
haut pourquoi parce que les il y a le
plateau du Tibet qui bloque un peu qui
qui qui bloque justement les les
précipitations et donc cette haridité on
la retrouve on la rrouveudessus ça monte
un peu plus haut et il est vrai que dans
cet ouvrage oasis où je traite de l'eau
L'eau désert et l'eau désert par
définition c'est un diè des surfaces
hein c'est c'est rien c'est rien du tout
hein et donc je traite de tout le Sara
en partant de Mauritanie Maroc partout
hein Libye je sais je passe par
l'Iran j'arrive en Chine et dans tous
ces dans tous ces déserts il y a des
populations mais il y a des populations
parce qu'en fait euh au au Néolithique
on va dire qu'il y a à peu près euh euh
il y a eu la il y a eu
euh une période très favorable au Sahara
entre - 11000 ans et - 7000 ans - 6000
ans c'est le Sahara était une savane
c'est pour ça qu'il y a des énormément
de de gravures et de peintures
néolithiques qui représentent même des
des girafes des éléphants et autres mais
au fur et à mesure que ça s'est aridifié
si vous voulez ben l'homme s s'est
déplacé vers les points où il y avait de
l'eau alors il y a des nappes
fréatriques très imp important dans ces
déserts par exemple sous la Libye et
l'Algérie il y a des nappes fréatiques
très importantes parfois cette nappe
fréatique effleure la surface donc les
gens s'y sont installer alors
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus facile
hein c'est c'est l'image que vous aviez
vu là avec des champs de céréales si
vous faites un forage dans la nappe de
l'Albien à à 500 m bon ok ça ça c'est
pas cher et puis vous avez de l'eau à
profusion enfin c'est c'est c'est une
réserve fossile on va dire que peut-être
que dans dans 100 ans il il y a plus y a
plus d'eau c'est un peu comme comme le
pétrole hein mais euh voyez où la
passion m'a amené techniquement alors
donc vous disiez c'est un parapente à
moteur c'est ça oui c'est ça ça été
inventé on a vu Nicolas hullo il y a
très longtemps qui qui était un pionnier
dans ce domaine le c'est c'est un
parapente effectivement avec un moteur
ça fait partie de la classe des des ULM
mais l'intérêt c'est que euh par rapport
à l'ULM c'est c'est quoi ça pèse moins
moins lour c'est c'est une classe du LM
mais la différence c'est que mon moteur
il pèse 20 kg je le mets dans une dans
une valise et j'étais il y a un mois aux
États-Unis j'étais il y a 8 jours en
Algérie je l'emmène partout alors la
difficulté évidemment c'est c'est c'est
de passer les frontières vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont particulièrement
vigilants mais ça le fait fréquemment
donc là on
aperçoit oui et non parce que si quand
je voyage seul je voyage discrètement
avec un bagage qui n'est pas trop gros
très bien bon ben c'est formidable hein
c'est ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que Francis que je connais depuis
longtemps il s'est vraiment étant
passionné de photos c'est la photo qui
l'a poussé à aller vers le par et de
façon à monter des images de vu d' alors
et donc il y a eu cet accident en
Albanie c'est ça mais il a pas que
celui-là en 2013 je suis tombé au Brésil
de 100 m mais bon je je me suis cassé la
colonne vertébrale et puis donc il y a
il y a 2 ans je me suis cassé le coup
mais j'ai j'ai la baraca on va dire et
j'ai la chance d'être parmi vous
aujourd'hui non mais je crois parce que
quoi il y a des changements de vent de
temps imprévisible il y a bon il faut il
faut faire save parce que tous ceux qui
font ça disent qu'il faut il faut voilà
il faut être très sérieux et les erreurs
sont sont souvent humaines il faut
évidemment pas voler dans des aérologies
trop compliquées mais en en Albanie
c'est simplement qu'à l'atterrissage ma
voile a accroché un un poteau et donc je
suis parti en vrille voyez donc c'est
une une grosse erreur bon tout va bien
non mais ce qu'il faut savoir d'après ce
qu'il nous avait dit Francis c'est que
vous savez il tient un appareil photo
non mais il tient aussi les suspens de
de par donc parfois j'ai un peu
l'impression que il se lâche un petit
peu voà c'est non non moi je reste au R
du sol plutôt un aventurier du dessert
vous non mais je préfère voir les images
de Francis qu alors parlons un peu de
l'actualité photo ben écoutez il y a
toujours comme d'habitude
malheureusement c'est à Paris mais on
peut citer y a d'abord une exposition de
ici non jusqu'au 3 jusou c'est ça il y a
une exposition pas loin d'ici à Sèvre si
vous voulez donc d'un certain Bernard
Ruau qui qui qui parle des hommes et des
lignes donc c'est une exposition qui est
dans la mairie de Sèvre donc pas loin
donc et il y a aussi quelques images
dans la rue d'ailleurs voilà je vous ai
mis quelques images donc donc c'est
assez intéressant donc je brconise mais
il faut se dépêcher parce que c'est
jusqu'au 2 décembus 2 décembre jus
dimanche voà bon c'est un peu limite
mais à côté de ça euh à partir du du 5
décembre il va y avoir à à Villain
sursène donc là nous sommes en plein
dans les ivelines une exposition c'est
nature en scène SC est la rivière le
fleuve voilà donc moi je vous invite à
aller voir parce qu'il y aura une
conférence avec la personne qui est
là-bas alors ça devrait durer cette
place de la place de la Libération juste
en face de la gare de comment s'appelle
de la gare de de Villen sursen donc vous
pouvez y aller en train il y a pas de
problè on va un peu vite
par on voit on voit quelque chose qui
n'a rien à voir avec ce qui se passe à
Villen ça on va à Paris mais c'est vous
qui avez fait des photos voilà c'est ça
pourquoi parce que on le sait à cause ou
en raison des Jeux Olympiques les les
baraques des bouquinistes disparaissent
avz raises ont été fermés hein ouais et
et effectivement il y a il y a un peu
les clans des bouquinis se sont
regroupés et
donc si vous voulez ils sont pas contre
qu'on enlève les les cases c'est ce
qu'il faut dire parce que par que si on
veut voir la scène quand il va y avoir
le
défilé donc il faut les enlever et
surtout ce qui demande c'est qu'on
remette leur cas en place voilà ce qu'il
y a c'est que c'est c'est historique et
ce qu' voudrait c'est qu'un fois que les
Jos sont terminés qu'on remette les leur
leur baraque de bouinist en place oui or
c'est pas ça qui va se passer
visiblement enfin c'est pas encore il y
a un autre projet qui il y aurait un
autre projet sous-jacent sousjassant qui
est frais avec choses plus modernes et
plus et et donc j'en a profiter pour
faire pourire pour faire ce travail si
vous voulez parce que ça fait ça faisait
longtemps que ça me courait dans
l'esprit de faire ce ce travail sur les
bouquinistes qui sont quand même quelque
chose comme disait sandard si vous
voulez c'est que Paris est la seule
ville au monde où le fleuve coule coule
entre deux deux livres absolument donc
parce que vous en avez r gauche r droite
oui des deux côtés et c'est c'est vrai
que son sont elles sont très très belles
sont elles sont touchantes quoi ces
photos mais c'est très difficile
toujours en noir et blanc hein ah oui
ben là je là c'est un c'est un vrai
accordéoniste d'aujourd'hui ça oui oui
oui alors c'est un accordéoniste qui sur
la passerelle des Arts et j'ai trouvé
que si vous voulez la passerelle des
Arts faisait un peu un lien entre la
rive gauche et la rive droite donc voilà
c'est pour ça que dans mon dans la
définition de mon travail j'ai pris du
plaisir à mettre ce personnage qui est
qui est quand même un petit un petit un
petit côté surprenant et puis bien sûr
ben écoutez on avait déjà parlé d'un
certain nombre d'expositions qui étaiit
à Paris donc donc si je remonte il y a
bien sûr coracore qui est à bouour où il
y a de très belles photos donc don un
portrait de doramar par je sais plus si
c'est mré ou quelque chose comme ça et
vous avez aussi le noir et blanc à à la
Bibliothèque François miléran oui c'est
toujours c'est exposition c'est toujours
mais il faut y aller parce que vraiment
si vous voulez c'est vraiment il y a des
photos à dominante noire et vous avez
des photos à dominante blanche ah très
bien donc on peut faire le la
comparaison entre ce deux types de
travaux qui sont quand même si vous
voulez alors il y a quelque chose qui
peut gêner que quelques gens ont évoqué
aussi c'est que par exemple on va voir
des photos de de Willy ris samsell Adams
en fait toute quartier Bresson et cetera
et cetera parce que il y a 300 photos
qui sont exposées et mais vous avez
aussi des comment dire on voit pas
toutes les photos de d'un auteur c'est
quelque chose qui s'appelle noir et
blanc ou c'est c'est c'est sur le thème
voilà le thème et c'est les auteurs plus
et ça si vous voulez Patrice c'est
quelque chose de très intéressant très
bien et puis vous avez des des derni
dernière chose alors il y a des une
exposition qui très intéressante aux
Archives nationales aussi dans Paris
c'est les 50 anes de Libé l'œil de lib
et je crois que c'est c'est les unes de
ce journal si vous voulez quand il y a
eu des grand évén trè bien ça ouais
ouais oui parce que qui était qui était
exposé en Arles cet été et donc làtait
celle que vous avez vu c'était même
exposition vous AZ et puis et puis vous
en avez beaucoup de vous en avez bal
passe de la défense à partir d'elle vous
avez Denis Maurice coloret Bach c'est à
la Guer du Point du Jour place Jean
Jean-Michel Bacter dans le 13e vous avez
Grégor
Créon qui est aussi donc rue du grenier
saint-lazard à Paris Ie donc à l'heure
actuelle si vous voulez vous avez quand
même profission de photos il y a les il
y a les oui il y a les lieux et puis il
y a les voilà c'est ça en puis et puis
quand vousz voir les bouinistes alors
les bouquinistes faites attention je
reviens dessus parce que si vous leur
demandez pas de de l'autorisation de les
photographi vous pouvez vous faire oui
c'est normal ça mais voilà il faut pas y
aller avec 300 non même dans le
désert son avis au sable il faut il faut
un peu une connivance avec le sujet
photographié merci beaucoup francisac je
on s'arrête là on s'arrête là la
prochaine fois on pourra parler de
peut-être d'autres sujets parce que j'en
ai d'autres dans le SAB dans la besass
donc voilà merci pour votre accueil
merci cl chose merci beaucoup francisac
donc je rappelle Buc héritage he qu'on
qu'on trouve voilà les quelques
librairies de de Buc et puis sur votre
site et puis sur votre site on peut
aussi trouverun je suppose à fait mais
oasis on le trouve également à dans le
commerce ou absolument absolument merci
beaucoup merci pour votre accueil
[Musique]
Patrice